siamo in un cassetto
secondo
il finiano
abbiamo giocato al primo gioco se non
l'avete visto vi lascio il link wing non
l'avete visto andate prima vedere quello
sono ritornati poi vedete il secondo
così non avrete degli spoiler avviso
questo è uno di quei giochi
paurosi rinite siete molto piccolini o
se vi fanno paura queste cose mi faccio
ora qua un link con video divertenti non
paurosi cliccate in questo link che vi
apparirà un wow quast invece vi
piacciono le cose paurose canteremo più
giusto vi ricordate questo gioco era
belli stimolo per loro di vedere cosa
succede nel nuovo aggiornamento i più
pronti bradipo cor lasciate un bel mi
piace perché se questo video le 10 mila
mi piace proveremo un altro gioco
paurosa non vi dico ancora il nome lo
scoprirete
mettetevi comodi di siamo subito io
allora c'è scritto segui il coniglio
bianco e scappa da
seguire il coniglio bianco come alice
nel paese delle meraviglie numero si
chiama cosa ci aspetterà in questa nuova
avventura da baby sitter e ora di
dormire il bambino è quello che pensi
questo è il coniglio bianco girati un po
intorno venisse
a un vestitino da
un'aperta andrà quasi più carino allora
la volta dobbiamo andare la bottiglia
dal frigo è amato dalla come cosa e
l'altro quindi l'inizio è simile
diamogli da mangiare anche l'albero di
natale lui è contento ma dobbiamo
cambiarlo quindi come l'altra volta
dobbiamo cambiarlo e poi se vi ricordate
no
diversi corpi demoniaco perché prendere
sta guardando sorride robello possiamo
cambiare la firma
arrivi via mare
eccole qui allora lo che abbiamo da tre
è stato vitale sarà stata fatta ma com'è
allora dice di portarlo su a dormire
dormirà dormiranno voglio
spegnere la luce e adesso dice che
chiudono la porta ok dice di andare ad
aspettare i genitori ea guardare la tv o
cremati genitrice di aspettarli vedi
speriamo che riusciamo però guardiamo la
tv anzi ne o meglio non conosco i miei
genitori perché se il bambino e così
abbiamo tormentando sbagliati si è
svegliato il bambino andiamo a calmarlo
ha aperto la porta da solo dove
bambino attento buttano fuori
all'improvviso
ho
sentito un rumore tifo figlio ha aperto
la porta adesso pure chiusa andiamo a
guardare la tv se dai che cosa può
succedere dobbiamo guardare la tv no che
crea può succedere cosa succederà mai
apro le porte con la sola forza del
pensiero sistemoni addormentando sapere
qualcosa abbiamo sbloccato l'uscita
capitolo 2 il bambino ride e dice guarda
guarda non è divertente e la baby sitter
dice ti avevo detto di non farlo che
cosa ho capito il gioco dobbiamo aprire
la porta consiglio
le dice di seguire
siamo mai un modello che diceva a
seguire il coniglio bianco ok ma stiamo
seguendo l'immagine del coniglio bianco
c'è la ix20 perché facevo in un hotel
[Musica]
credetemi ha detto non ti preoccupare
quanti piani che ci sono non ci farà
seguito il bambino no no
povero piccolo coniglio so cosa stai
cercando ma non lo troverei qua è mio
dice il dottore sul quale dottor escluso
come uscito il dottore si fa sempre più
strana questa storia pronto il sensore
un po inquietante
dal presento fuoco la pulsantiera perché
arriva bloccati dentro l'ascensore
qualcosa non lo è arrivato ricordo ecco
dove dice il coniglio bianco guarda che
porta magari c'è qualche sta chiusa
trovo un altro ascensore il coniglio
bianco ovunque si mangia si aspetta c'è
qualcosa da noi chiuse quando vuoi dove
ci porterà questo coniglio bianco non
dobbiamo fidarci
ma
se rimane vivo
noto coniglio bianco moro dove siamo
nella casa di qualcun altro e 7 a casa
sua a casa sembra casa dal no non è
stata sua ei papà non riesco a capire
garda una chiave con una luna forse
quella chiave ci serve per aprire la
porta col coniglio bianco è andato a
finire quel bambino può prenderlo ma
scompare ogni volta del mio vicino
ma la grecia ne aveva già e troverò la
bambina bambino chiariti nella curia
vabbè bambino come la maggiore questo
dobbiamo trovare con gli usa dal forno
c'è qualcosa
cibo che c'è qualcosa sembra tipo nulla
e quindi forse dobbiamo suonare una
canzone al bambino per farla tormentare
la nanna
forse qui c'è qualcosa io l'altro pezzo
di spartito che in su
quindi vuol dire la ninna nanna del
resto come facciamo a suonarla qui c'è
un disco però se si può mettere questo
disco qui c'è un altro disco siamo
chiamati cerchiamo e giradischi e la
legge che prova a mettere uno dei dischi
preso no non l'ho preso prima sia quello
giusto cosa succederà se lo
è per cui si trova l'altro spartito
allora dobbiamo comporre tutte e tre
match ma c'è un'altra lilla 0
forse è questo quello giusto vediamo che
sto dovrebbe andare qui alla fine alla
fine si è per ora che cosa facciamo
forse dobbiamo cercare dallo stop per
comporlo allora circa un paio che fare
un pezzo che questo forse lo spartito lo
dobbiamo mettere fenomeno questo che
bello non è che noi suoneremo qualche
cosa strana che si ipotizzano che cosa
vuoi che ci succede vediamo che
ipnotizzano il bambino e non noi vediamo
questo è l'ultimo sono io ma l'hai
ok
la mia nonna per il bambino ho capito
quindi adesso forse riusciamo a
prendergli la chiave aspetta deve finire
di suonare
si è arrabbiato
ma guarda coraggio pulsante dove qui
passaggio dei camion che ci dobbiamo
inchinare come si fa ad infilare non mi
ricordo ok passiamo attraverso questo
spazio questo sistema sono di quei
sotterranei della casa ho paura che qua
succede qualcosa di brutto
cos'è questo guardarci un disco tradisco
per king lullaby quindi è la dobbiamo
far suonare questo e non in andando a
del re si non so cosa succederà al
bambino spero solo che si addormentino
che si tratti non essere me stessa demo
riecco come l'altra volta ok allora
questo sicuramente il disco giusto
vai questo lo lasciamo qui che non si
sarà la flai
ok forse alla senato la chiave dobbiamo
trovare il bambino
sbrigati prima che si trasformi noi dove
tre eccolo
norme sulla chiave sì sì ma il picco
di ben venti forse che la cercarsi
dell'auto di rumori sarà poi la chiave
no no chiamo l'ascensore però quello che
funziona perché questo non so no dice
che non c'è elettricità o no c'è un
altro coniglio ok andiamo dico allora
pizzetti qui c'è adesso dobbiamo
arrivare nelle tre città si
neghi whiting allora che cos'è questo
batteria forse si è rotto il fusibile ha
finito via bello che parli una possibile
pero sia quello giusto
funziona forse si è rotto anche questo o
violenti la rotta anche questo quindi
dobbiamo cercare un fusibile rosa adesso
prova aprire uno di questi aprile di
questi armadietti
che cos'è questo il
degli scacchi del real è però
nonno che cosa vorrà dire ah ecco è
visibile rosa però dopo ricordati di
prendere questo degli scacchi del rapper
si sicuramente ci servirà con il bambino
dagli il pezzo degli scacchi
momento a poco prezzo di questo dice no
ha tolto è possibile ecco perché ecco
perché
bisogna di strano con qualcosa
sicuramente si è chiuso ha preso quello
rosa che ci provo campoli finiremo
quindi prima di allora dobbiamo fermare
il bambino del possibile quindi gli
dobbiamo dare qualcosa vediamo se c'è
qualcosa che hanno poco di distrarla
essere chiudessimo dentro gli armadietti
ecco allora aspetta stiamo sbloccando ma
che siano possiamo dimenticare
43 allora un numero 43 forse c'è
qualcosa di
417 per di non
andare giù
forse dobbiamo mettere il bambino ha
detto tavolo qua sotto
quasi sto divertendo
ok
speriamo che adesso funzioni 10 l'unico
problema è che
secondo me si è arrabbiato si è
arrabbiato pepper prendi il pezzo di
scacchi magari si serve dopo ok era
questa la strada giusta non andartene
sei iscritto no mica c'era ruby e
conoscenza
sbrigati o no
[Musica]
ah che bello si trasformano boss
abbiamo perso clicca per svegliarti ok
siamo ancora aspetta l'ascensore dice e
sopravvivi
mentre aspettiamo le borghesie comoda
avremo questa non è bloccata scappiamo
di qua le staffe bloccata
questa è bloccata
lo chiamano abbiamo capito subito
seguito dal signor sentiamo di qua
allora provino a chiave la sopra
prendiamo subito la chiave f e poi
dovete puntare dritto dritto per dritto
abbiamo la forza scappa e adesso
questo è bloccata notate scappa che può
scappa scappa si è bloccata di nuovo
la chiave sarà festa no lo sanno che
quella pallina poi quella con la luna
quella con la luna quello con una parte
e dall'altra parte nostra di nella
steppa serve anche questo serve che
questa
aprire tante porte
allora chiediamo la chiave blocchiamo
questa via perché poi poi adesso
dobbiamo andare di qua rendere la mia
dall'udinese triangolo allora la chiave
luna è questo vai in fantastico poi
presenti a venire qui e l'abbiamo presa
sblocchiamo
adesso
è arrivata una canzone bella ciao adesso
che cosa che mi fa proprio nel
burro l'ultimo capitolo questo è
l'ultimo capitolo l'uscita non lasciarmi
solo rimane qua per sempre grazie a
lei possiamo farcela stiamo ancora
nell'ascensore grado
mi sembra che si è tornato tutto normale
ciao davvero e ma lui è felice si sta
ascoltando la musica sta ballando ma
questa è un'altra casa sembra quasi un
bambino normale allora cittadina all
innanzitutto provate aprire quel cose di
giocate in qua sotto allora la chiave
servirà sicuramente per qualcosa ma non
quelli che dire lasciamo frequentata
libri quella cucina quindi sarà qui è
l'opposto
proviamo a salire al piano di sopra che
sia best dice di dargli da mangiare
abbiamo gli do mangiare prima
forma di critica no poveri non fanno
maggiore di una felice
dice di cambiarlo di nuovo per questo
puzzo lento nei sei pronto per
scopare tutto puzzolente sul divano
prendila bottiglie dal frigo che di
nuovo ma io appena mangiato
ok
però mangia kaki
cambiarlo è qualcosa che non quadra
forse dobbiamo seguire il coniglio
bianco
no basta e mangiato abbastanza se
qualcuno sa se io salto sopra dobbiamo
seguire
fermato lì a cambiare pannolini abbiamo
bisogno della chiave col cuore era molto
bene apriamo queste forze vediamo se in
queste porte bloccata quindi la dobbiamo
cercare specchiamo
starà facendo
questi treni stanno in onda solo da soli
o no ops stiamo nel corridoio di nuovo
sarà arrabbiato e affamato ciao però
non lo dobbiamo portare a dormire quale
sarà la sua stanza e non questa figura
che dobbiamo per forza portarlo a
dormire licia scoraggiarlo lì
allora queste stanze sembrano tutte
bloccate questa no però questo è aperta
questa aperta vediamo questa è bloccata
in un labirinto questo hotel perché la
stanza c'è scritto
immaginarie e tre cose confortanti che
ci sono più né dormi adesso forse da c'è
una porta che si apre a chi ha chiuso la
porta
ovvero puzzolo ha detto di nuovo di
portarlo a dormire in un labirinto si
sta ripetendo
cos'era
che cosa
bambino sta giocando con i fuochi
d'artificio
ok portiamola giornaliera erano
adesso questa prima non c'era anzi non
c'erano erano solo le due sul lato mi
sono allora lo lasciamo qui a dormire
dai dorme ciao
si sta arrabbiando lo sento dormi e nei
programmi fare un giro da questa parte
magari scopriamo qualcosa no mi sa che
dobbiamo per forza uscire da qui di
nuovo passare da questa porta che si
chiude da sola e guarda l'orologio
magari c'è qualcosa sul giusto che
lancetta estranea di nuovo c'è scritto
no
non dobbiamo prenderlo vedi te l'avevo
detto dall'inizio di lasciarlo lì in
questa volta il coniglio bianco ci ha
detto di non
prendere il bambino della della cosa un
po strana
nola saro li lasciano e titti
è sempre lo stesso bambino sì
ma anche io che lo sta sparando fra
facevo giocare lui che sta sparando
delle scorregge malefiche queste si
muovo la sua stanza
provare entrare nella sua stanza ok
ma ci mandi abbiamo di nuovo di qua
secondo me si sta arrabbiando tantissimo
allora dice guarda la tv ti senti stanco
dove ci attende trasportato questa tv
siamo tornati nella stanza con
l'orologio
dobbiamo fare in modo di non guardarli
bce altrimenti la tv si teletrasporta
acqua quindi tutti mi sento di non
portare la mamma non posso saltare
proprio
mario di club
ma allora
ce l'abbiamo fatto ancora non dobbiamo
guardare la tv per dare una giornata
bellissima
questo gioco è fantastico no no no
cellula dalla tv ne va al bambino dentro
la tv ci credo che ce l'abbiamo fatta
qua allora dice
porta il bambino a dormire di nuovo
girate molto stanco e molto arrabbiato
secondo me mamma mia quanto fa paura con
quella faccia ma se ci sentivamo qui sul
trono no meglio di no sbrigati
quindi lo dobbiamo prendere adesso è
scappato e voi che adesso non fanno
sparire uno scorreggione
demoniaco arrivi di nuovo sparato qui da
qualche posto
ecco cosa c'è che
attento
ci sono degli occhi che ci guardano
che cos'è non lo so
o no forse sei arrabbiato un pochettino
un po tanto che questa dovevo fare
rieccolo piccolo da anni viene
portiamo a dormir lo sa
questo mi sembra a posto sicuro dove
metterlo a dormire per un bambino di
omonia così
che cosa è successo abbiamo bene non lo
so perché siamo di nuovo qua bravo a
prenderlo adesso e quant'altro pesca pon
o meno tornare lì ma dobbiamo fare
qualcosa di diverso ma che cosa odiamo
portar da un'altra parte
buttiamo lo giudico aaron buone idee
alla fine
ha
funzionato
eccone alcuni
secondo me è arrabbiatissima e
non ho visto qualcosa per non lo voglio
vedere che torniamo qui riusciti a voi
che non ci sia lui
ovviamente lo sapevo di
[Musica]
qualità
di qua
ho preso seri quasi però se noi uscirà
di la bravo e a questo punto io sono
andato qui a destra
e devo aprire ai babbi passare poi
bisogna passare di qua
non ci credo ce l'hai fatto dobbiamo
giocare a nascondino e dice non ho
potere non dice non andartene quelle una
bambola non credo sia lui no una bambola
vediamo che cosa li prendiamo per
giocare questo
coniglio bianco
apriamo
no
no no no no no sono risolti ciao bambino
quindi dobbiamo saper fare subito a
scappare gira subito festa
cosa sono queste cose non capisco non lo
so
c'è scritto filmone ciao mare si scrive
così io scappo
ma che passavo di aver visto nella loro
la freccia anche se non erano freccia
notizie o milioni girone perché
lavoretto da prima oggi ormai non vi
germanico mi tiro mai non mi tiro mai
perso apri la porta
dove vado se un bambino gente che va
bene niente aiuto ai fatti
non capisco punte di vaio si è rotto
treno e doccia dove andare di qua ok poi
di qua faccia in uscita aiuto ci sta
bloccato o si apre la porta
è tutto bianco
corri piccolo coniglio non sei l'unico
che ci sarà sempre ancora qualcosa
siamo riusciti
mi
domando come lui non ci arrabbiatissimo
la cava benissimo
parte bellissimo lo stesso per noi che
siamo avanti di giochi sogno bellissimo
che voto gli date da una 10 da un 9 e
mezzo era fatto non benissimo anzi
domanda per voi preferite yellow oa gli
uochi scrivetelo nei commenti e ora vi
lasciamo qua quattro casalinghe su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
su quella che preferite